You know the scene.
You know the story.
For Tim McGraw and Faith Hill, though, it
was about way more than just playing their
parts.
Their personal reaction to what happened will
blow you away.
As the Yellowstone universe continues to expand,
the Western drama's first spin-off has wrapped
its inaugural season.
1883 is a prequel to the record-breaking series
and chronicles the Dutton family's ancestors'
grueling journey from Texas to Montana.
Before the season came to an end, it was announced
that more episodes would follow — and fans
are already eager to see what comes after
the shocking finale.
Episode 10, "This Is Not Your Heaven," sees
the Duttons' eldest daughter Elsa Dutton recovering
from the arrow wound she sustained in the
previous episode.
Many 1883 fans speculated that Elsa would
survive the infection that began to set in,
given that she is a main character and narrates
the series.
However, the finale proved this theory wrong.
Despite Elsa's condition improving as the
group pushed forward on their long journey,
things suddenly took a turn for the worse.
During "This Is Not Your Heaven," Elsa must
grapple with her doomed fate and bid an emotional
farewell to her family.
By the end of the episode, Elsa has succumbed
to the infection, declaring she is unafraid
before finally passing away.
"I'm not scared…
I'm not scared."
That final father-daughter scene was clearly
hard to watch for many, and 1883 stars Tim
McGraw and Faith Hill have admitted that the
entire episode was difficult for them to shoot.
In an interview with Variety, the real-life
couple opened up about the tragic death of
their on-screen daughter.
Describing the arc as one of the most incredible
stories she had ever read, Hill told the publication:
"As a mom, I can't even allow myself to go
there.
I cannot.
It's really hard, even now, to talk about,
because once the tears start coming, I can't
stop them.
I would tell the directors, if we start going,
it's going to be hard for me to stop."
While James Dutton gets to be with Elsa during
her final moments, Margaret must stay behind
with their other children, watching helplessly
as her daughter is brought away to choose
her final resting place.
This scene, in particular, shook Hill during
filming.
She told Variety:
"Imagine knowing that your child is going
to die and you cannot be by their side?
I can't even imagine it ever.
I have not recovered."
Hill went on to say that she also cannot imagine
how this loss will affect James and Margaret's
marriage.
The actress has been open about how 1883 takes
an emotional toll on her, noting the death
of her character's sister-in-law earlier in
the season still makes her cry.
Meanwhile, Tim McGraw told Variety that, when
he read the last scripts for Season 1 of 1883
with Hill, they couldn't stop crying.
He said:
"I mean, ugly, boohoo crying.
I was a blubbering idiot.
It was just so well-written, so devastating
and heartbreaking, but at the same time, so
on point and poignant for what Yellowstone
turned out to be."
McGraw added:
"It just gives you all the reasons in the
world why they fight so hard for that land
and why their family fights so hard to keep
what they have.
It just made perfect sense."
No matter how much sense it made, though,
he was still struck by Elsa's death.
McGraw explained that he had to make an effort
not to get too emotional too early during
the scene — but struggled because Isabel
May looks like she could be his own daughter.
"It's hard as a parent, playing that role
— you don't want to go to any dark places
in your mind about your kid.
So you have to keep trying to block that out
and still be in the moment with the character
that you're playing [...] but the lines do
get blurry."
However, he also agreed that this moment played
an important role in the greater story — even
if fans aren't happy about it.
McGraw explained:
"It's going to be a good thing that they hate
that ending, because it has to be that way
and they know it.
It's gonna be devastating.
Why would you watch stuff if it doesn't purge
your emotions?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.